now as part of our ongoing investigation
I bring the calls between President
Obama and president elect Trump directly
to you the American people here's some
more whoa
you like the Betsy DeVos bed for
education hated FEMA new chief for
Treasury Hayden got through DPA the
fossil fuel guys hate it how about that
Christ in the head of HUD makes no spend
payment bad dog batter Haven okay that's
rock you've been a big help
I'm gonna go ahead with all of them what
Pakistan Kazakhstan white this I believe
hospital pharmacy word meaning country
nerd gotcha hilarious well the Lincoln
Bedroom
what about it he's not still in it is he
because a lot isn't afraid to go in
there another general to my cabin no you
think you've picked enough general chris
Christie just recommended another one
general so I got a girl the big guy he
loves to eat
hello hey Brad what is it
I went to see one of those black
Christmas movies you know the ones with
the sweaters okay well so you think they
could have those for white people
that's called every other Christmas
movie you're right I think I finally
understand white privilege Jesus yes
Lonnie is doing Christmas cards what's
your address 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
[Applause]
I've got a joke for you which black and
white and red all over I don't know it's
you and me covered in marinara sauce why
are we going to marinara sauce there's a
fantasy of mine I don't think that's all
five of a joke you're a joke your whole
presidency is a joke goodbye Donald can
we do the marinara thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you